this program is brought to you by Emory
University
well may 14th 2010 I'll never forget
that date I just had an anniversary and
it was an unusual feeling because I sort
of felt I was wearing this bulletproof
jacket for help
I was always considered to be in great
condition and my wife came home one
afternoon and I was laying on the floor
and couldn't move and she normally
wouldn't have come in for very long but
she came in heard the dog
you know making some weird noises very
unusual for her and wanted to come into
the room and saw me lay on the floor my
wife was there to to rescue me and and I
praise the Lord for the fact that it
wasn't very long after I had the stroke
that we were in the ambulance and headed
to Emory
I had a wave of you know physicians who
had worked with me you know through my
you know conditions and you know if like
an angel came in and there was dr. Sarah
Blanton who actually told me a little
bit about the a study that was only
being conducted and I believe Washington
DC Los Angeles California and fortunate
for me Atlanta Georgia and she asked me
if I would be interested in getting
involved with this program called I care
or ASAP and you know not knowing a whole
lot about it I just said with my wife
and asked her to if I missed understood
something that she would just set in and
be a part of it and after she listened
to the you know the great counseling you
know we thought why not it's an
experimental program and I you know I
always wanted to be in a position where
I could help others
it was almost like going back to school
and being in elementary where I want to
write I was an artist so I wanted to be
able to write again and write
effectively where people could
understand what I what it was that I was
putting on the paper and we started out
with a Jake the first J let's it was
horrible and you know through the course
of time I was able to make a jaded look
illegible and being able to satisfy
myself you know coach wants you to
satisfy what a coach wants out of you
but then you have to have that inner
drive to say okay now I've done
something to make him feel good or her
feel good
how do I make myself feel good and so I
began to do the J and the J look good
and I went on with the O and I did the
Jo E
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University